Blasphemous 2 is just as good as the
original today I want to go over the
story of Blasphemous 2 to figure out
what's really going on here as well as
critique its quality along the way as I
have quite a few things to say about
this game's story we have a lot to talk
about though so I don't want to take up
more time than necessary before we begin
though a huge shout out to Team 17 for
providing me an early code so I can have
some extra time to dissect the game's
narrative and obviously spoiler warning
ahead we're going to be talking about
this game and its previous installment
in full so come back once you've
finished your playthrough if you need a
quick refresher on the first game I made
a video about it on the channel That
will be linked in the eye in the top
right or at the end of this video with
that out of the way though let's get
started
so Blasphemous 2 picks up right after
the events of the previous games DLC
wounds of Evan tide as a brief recap the
penitent one was sent by the miracle to
replace Escobar and continue the cycle
of worship but with the new DLC we
learned that the miracle was actually
being controlled by the high Wills
another Godlike entity but they had also
underestimated the penitent one who with
the help of chrysanta was able to defeat
them thanks to the high Wills dying
though all their Creations went with it
which is why the Twisted one or the very
first miracle the Pennington one and
their sword the mayakopa all died with
it the final scene we saw for the game
was a giant heart housing of being
inside it that towered over the line of
custodia Blasphemous 2 elaborates on
this in the opening cutscene as we first
see chrysanthe bleeding before stabbing
herself with her sword right near her is
another being who at the moment doesn't
have a name but will soon learn his
avaterno shortly after we hear that the
city of the Blessed name Rose up to the
sky being held by three statues above
the city is the same giant heart from
the previous game in the opening
dialogue says that the miracle was about
to give birth to a new child as if we
needed to add more confusion to the mix
the following scene shows the penitent
one waking from his coffin so already we
have a lot of questions and not a lot of
answers and unfortunately we won't be
getting those answers for a while
holding his coffin though is deo gracias
and a statue of him we find later tells
us that he was to watch over the casket
of the Pennington one until he arises
meaning he sat beside us until he died
these statues are part of the game's
upgrade abilities but like most items in
the game they have lore descriptions
that fill in lots of details about the
world that the game doesn't outright
Telus which is where the bulk of our
information is going to come from on top
of Deo gracias the Mia culpa is also
gone fortunately we have a new selection
of weapons to choose from the new
weapons followed the standard archetypes
of high damage low speed high speed low
damage and a balanced third option these
not only enhance the gameplay and give
the player more freedom but they also
add to one of the core parts of
blasphemus's gameplay the exploration
after choosing our weapon we can test
its Effectiveness on the very first boss
The Faceless one chisel of Oblivion
sadly there isn't really much to say
about this specific boss as it's not
like in the first game where the first
boss comes back as a regular enemy
towards the latter half of the game as
you never see a being like this ever
again so I really just think it's an
excuse to throw all bosses and super
early so we can test our weapon the
design of this location is interesting
though as it's called the Repose of The
Silent One referring to the final
resting place of the penitent one but
judging by the statues everywhere it
seems like he was revered by many likely
because of his past Deeds thanks named
saving custodia from the torment of the
high Wills also helping out the NPCs
with their personal issues speaking of
custodia a natural thing to be asking
right now would be how long it's been
since the previous game and it seems
like it's been a very long time as under
the main town is a location called the
mother of mothers the same place in
Blasphemous 1. in the original the
mother of Mother's church was opulent
and large but now it's extremely run
down and abandoned it serves as a nice
thematic representation of the world as
the church used to be one of the highest
locations in the game but now it's
almost the lowest point the player could
reach it's also a nice Nostalgia trip
for those that played the first game as
the tree that's brought it from the
first miracle is still here but much
more withered than before and quite a
few items have descriptions that talk
about old characters like ezrus and
rendento the church being this Run
download does show how long it's been
since the first game and also how many
people have decided to move on with out
the miracle its influence over custodia
was cut thanks to the penitent one so
many of its worshipers Stop Believing in
it after going years without answers to
their prayers and in the case of
Blasphemous a God's life and power are
based on their influence so the miracle
losing their power is akin to not
existing that's what leads me to believe
that the time between the high Wills
dying and the Heart appearing in the sky
is a lot longer than the game makes it
out to be as the miracle disappeared for
quite a bit of time in between games
outside the cave though is a woman named
a nun thiato who has a task for us the
miracle is about to give birth to a new
child above the city of the Blessed name
and she wants us to stop it to do this
we're going to need to find something
called the three regrets and then Ascend
to the highest of peaks in order to
reach the heart but stopping us as an
archive fraternity of penitence who
serve as the miracle Sentinels their
specific names are orespina benedicta
Odon lesmus and avaterno the father of
the penitence you'll notice very quickly
that a lot of Blasphemous 2's structure
is similar to that of the first game
before we had to find the three
humiliations which gave us access to the
second half of the game but now the
humiliations have been replaced with the
three regrets and this continues on to
the next area as the city and by
extension this whole game is host to all
manner of strange individuals the health
vendor is a large woman who seems normal
at first but over time seems to have her
skin peeled off by the cherubs that fly
around her or there's the magical vendor
who's a literal talking hand but somehow
that's not even the strangest thing
about this game as the ones that I think
are tied for first are the guy whose
body is filled with honey and the other
NPC named Cesario who has a stitched
down breast that can somehow lactate
similar to Blasphemous one though there
is a consistency amongst the NPC's and
bosses and that's that the miracle is
punishing them sometimes with purpose
other times unnecessarily we'll delve
into the bosses soon but some NPCs like
the aforementioned honeycomb men are
unsure what they did to deserve this
fate others though are aware of why such
as Cesario who cut off his own wife's
breasts and hope that the miracle could
recognize his devotion defeating his
child as well as Costo who robbed many
people and as a result became a
deformity it seems like the miracle is
doing what it did in the first game
where its blessing some and cursing
others but the manifestations this time
around are all curses yet punishing
those that did bad things but it hasn't
granted someone something for being kind
it's just punishment after punishment
whether it's unjust or not the horrific
imagery here has certainly been turned
up a notch in this entry as every one of
these beings is just grotesque in their
own way but that grotesqueness is
actually what got me interested in them
in the first place is a questline
evolving around a guy with a stitched
down breast surely has to go somewhere
pretty much every NPC had me going that
some of the most absurd I've ever
seen I wonder where this goes and from a
honeycomb man to a talking hand to a
full-on riddle in a sealed envelope of
the NPCs and Discovery adds to the
exploration of the game and intrigued me
immensely but I think a large reason why
this was also bizarre to me is that I
lack the cultural context another
character who was equally as disturbing
was Joe cinero from the first game he
was a giant cherub who was seen standing
inside the recently split open corpse of
a bull many of you in the comments
pointed out to me that this is a
reference to a bowl of the same name
that had killed a bullfighter back in
the 1800s while that specific detail
didn't help piece together the story of
Blasphemous it did at least explain
where there was a dead bull right in
front of me I say this because I'm
almost certain the devs are doing the
same thing again as the Kobe hata as an
exact reference of the same outfit the
first time we meet her she asks us to
find her sisters who are also dressed in
similar clothing the Kobe hata though is
actually a real outfit that gained some
popularity in the 16th century where
women would cover everything but one of
their eyes it seems to have become a
lost Tradition at this point thanks to
being outlawed in the 1900s but the town
of vijer in Spain seems to still utilize
it as there's a statue near one of the
town's castles while I can find some of
the references a lot of them are lost on
me as I'm not well versed in
Christianity especially the Spanish side
of it so like the last video If a boss's
name or NPC's design sticks out to you
let me know in the comments I'd love to
hear about it
continuing from where we left off though
it's time to tackle the three regrets
the three bosses that hold these are
radamus Les Mason or Spina you'll
recognize the last two as they are the
two of the five penitents that unnamed
theaters spoke of sorority 40 of the way
through our Hit List seeing as the game
is a metroidvania though we're able to
tackle these bosses in any order we wish
so we'll discuss them in the order I
took them on radamus was the Confessor
of the monastery he worked at he was
tasked with hearing the guilts and sins
of all the monks who came to absolve
themselves of it so they can continue
their lives free of sin after enough
time he started to grow old and feeble
but due to the generations of guilt and
sin he had heard it somehow kept him
alive he no longer needed the basic
necessities that other humans would need
like food water or sleep he didn't even
experience pain or pleasure either only
the burden of those that spoke to him
only existed inside his body the monks
had taken advantage of this and used the
Confessor as a tool and a prisoner in
their sacraments it became too much for
him to bear though as after enough time
thousands of voices sprouted from his
body speaking all kinds of sins and
guilt likely the same ones people told
them throughout the years the sound was
so deafening that it eroded the very
walls of the monastery causing it to
collapse almost as if the sins
themselves wanted to be buried which is
by the area surrounding it is covered in
sand after defeating radamus were taken
into the dream and we can see what his
true form is most of his dialogue is
just repeating what we had just talked
about with the added line that he was
tasked regarding the Miracles sacred
regret this is referring to the cutscene
that follows this conversation this
specific scene is actually split into
three parts with each part belonging to
each regret so we'll Circle back to this
in just a moment
the second regret is obtained from
lesbis the incorrupt sacristan halfway
through the fight though he's joined by
another boss called the sleeping in
Fanta according to his statue item
description he was decapitated by a few
inquisitors for crimes unknown he
specifically called a martyr in the text
so maybe he went against the head of the
church at the time either way while his
head rolled across the ground the
inquisitors were too focused on making
sure that judgment was passed that they
didn't notice that a little girl had
taken his head and ran away she decided
to take the head to an abandoned church
and place it in an urn that used to hold
old relics going off lesmus's intro
dialogue we can assume that the miracle
had reanimated his head and attach it to
his metallic body that he now inhabits
in fact you can actually see his real
head in the stomach of the armor you get
the sense that lesmith doesn't want this
though as he states that it feels like
he's being directed by other forces to
carry out their Wills his full name also
ties back into this idea as incorrupt is
likely related to incorruptability which
is the belief that some people's corpses
don't decompose due to their immense and
holy Devotion to God and lesmus is sort
of Incorruptible thanks to the miracle
it's honestly pretty compelling and
shows how toxic the miracle has become
it is doing the exact same thing the
high wheels did with it back in the
first game it's causing chaos by
granting certain wishes and prayers even
if they don't make sense as for the
sleeping in fonto weather it's safe to
assume that this is the girl who took
his head when he was decapitated her
name also seems to be liviana as you can
find a spell of her blade attack that
she uses throughout the fight and the
word sleeping in Fanta is used in the
description with the name liviana being
the name of the spell itself I do also
have an additional fear regarding lesmus
although it's a bit spotty even for my
standards my theory is that lesmus is
either related to or is kierras from the
first game my main reasoning is that out
of both games are the only two bosses
that have this pill or a fire attack in
addition to kierce's own dialogue which
is about him being burned to death by
various inquisitors who was also seen as
a martyr furthermore the miracle just
like lesmus reanimated him by constantly
Reviving his body whenever the Flames
are killing kiris also has his own San
Benito which is the pointed helmet all
the penitents wear except his was made
of cloth which coincidentally is the
same color as the cloth and handsome
Elizabeth in the dream after the fight
in it does sound like a lot of evidence
but it's not perfect now if I recall I
do believe that lesmus was actually an
unused boss from the first game that had
a similar move set to keirs which is why
the two are so similar as lesmus was
likely the first draft of what would
become kirs like a lot of this game
though many details are unclear so just
like the influences and religious
references if there's something I got
incorrect or you have a different
interpretation of feel free to let me
know in the comments down below
regardless I've always liked seeing
prior games concept art and cut content
be fully realized in a sequel as it's a
nice callback for fans who remember the
old games and lesmus is no exception
our final boss is our second to five
penitence or Espino from the comfort
Unity of the embroiderers orospina is
kind of disturbing as she mentions how
anyone who enters her domain is pray for
her to toy with her statue description
isn't even about a deep personal
backstory it's just a three paragraph
tale about her toying with one of her
victims that managed to survive their
initial encounter talking about how the
victim felt fear as he attempted to
cling on to whatever life he had left
while orespina laughed at his pain and
suffering the reason why people even
come here is because many assume that
it's abandoned and still filled with the
riches that were left behind obviously
this isn't true but orespina doesn't
seem too interested in dispelling the
rumor that the embroiderers are gone as
she seems to love hunting any
unsuspecting foe who enters its Halls
like I said it's not a really deep
personal story like the previous two as
it's just a tale about her wanting to
kill people which is admittedly slightly
disappointing as the game doesn't even
bother elaborating on what the miracle
had to do with this she could have been
this sadistic from the start but it's
also possible that the miracle had
changed her but the miracle itself is
never mentioned in anything related to
her a large reason why is because it's
not the bosses them cells that are
important here but more so the cutscene
we get after they do add to the World
building of the game though but if the
statues and NPCs do that enough already
but afterwards is the final piece of the
cutscene which we now have the full
story of in addition to the city in the
sky now being lowered to our level one
thing you'll have noticed is that the
three regrets have images of three
people more specifically the father the
mother and the child from the cutscene
long ago a married couple wanted to have
kids but due to certain circumstances
whether it be infertility or other
health related issues they were
unsuccessful eventually after enough
praying the miracle heard their plea and
the couple gave birth to a healthy boy
except he was maybe too healthy as he
was a full-grown Man by the time he was
born naturally the mom died from the
birth but the others alongside them also
seemed to have died due to some
Affliction the miracle was disappointed
in the lack of faith and devotion that
had occurred during its absence for the
confirming that it's been quite a while
since the first game Soto's newest
creation as a deformity this is likely
why we are gathering the regrets this
time around as the miracle might regret
this act the references here are pretty
heavy-handed as it's very clearly trying
to relay this to the birth of Christ as
the setting and characters are
practically the same Mary is also known
as the Virgin Mary as she was
impregnated by God through the Holy
Spirit implying that God had a hand in
the pregnancy the same way the miracle
had a hand in this couple's pregnancy
it's also the Holy Trinity but with a
Blasphemous style twist as instead of
the Father Son and the Holy Spirit it's
the father mother and the son with the
biggest difference being that it's not
the ideal Holy Trinity that the miracle
plotted out to be the being that this
couple gave birth to is called the
witness and it's actually someone we can
talk to early on in the game underneath
the mother of Mother's church we find a
being called the Philly or Sentinel of
the emery after defeating them were sent
into the dream again and are introduced
to the witness he tells us that we are
speaking to the narrative voice of the
witness as his actual body is inside the
golden urn right next to us all this
though is admittedly really bizarre as
it's located in the lowest part of the
map behind a random unknown boss on top
of the fact that this is one of the
fights yerma can help us with which is
someone I'll talk about later but it's
all really confusing as I have no idea
how any of these connect in any way but
we at least ever knew objective as the
witness wants us to find the keys that
unlock the cages of the Five Doves that
sit above his corpse
the first key is given to us by one of
the pilgrims who is found here but the
rest are going to come from our hit list
and then some just like the statues the
keys also provide us with information
that is related to the being we got them
from like the aforementioned Pilgrim who
actually talks about the witness it says
that one day the miracle melted glass
and an urn and dressed it with gold said
it could properly display the body of
the witness he was put into this urns
that he may be Incorruptible said his
testimony remains Immortal as for the
rest of the keys though they'll tell us
the story of the other individuals who
came with their own locations the first
to appear on our map is the Basilica of
the absent faces whose boss is benedicta
of the Endless Orson the group is a
large Congregation of sisters who
watched over the Dead In Perpetual
prayer it seemed to be an incredibly
large group at that as one sister would
be dedicated to one person for the rest
of their life these women never prayed
for anyone else but the person they were
assigned to and once they died another
sister would take their place at the
prayers could continue just like any
other typical night though a new
Cardinal had arrived but benedicta must
have said something different about this
being as they immediately whipped out
afraid scroll that would seal her fate
apparently whoever uttered the words
written on this parchment would be
imprisoned in internal prayer unable to
stop until they died of starvation to
this day though none of the sisters
seemed to know why she did such a thing
and it will likely never be known seeing
as she is the defender of the miracle I
wonder if the miracle saw this devotion
and decided to keep her alive as it says
that you're to pray until you die the
other sisters were able to take breaks
and do normal everyday things unlike
benedicta where every waking moment was
spent praying for this one Cardinal but
seeing as she's still alive it's
possible that the Miracle made her
Eternal in some way so she could pray
for eternity
after her defeat a new building arises
from the sea of ink called the sunken
cathedral which houses Odon and his men
they were a group of sailors who
traveled along the sea until a wave
capsized their ship causing them to take
it to its dark watery depths what
shocked the men is that not only did
they arrive shortly after believing that
they survived the crash but they were
also inside a giant Cathedral the men
had looked to their Captain Odom for
guidance who immediately knew that their
new goal was to defend this place until
death as the salt here had granted them
another chance at life
our fourth key comes from sonoda him of
the Thousand voices located in the
severed Tower oddly enough the tower is
upside down but it seems like it was
built with that in mind for some reason
as the miracle was the one that nailed
the face down sonodo though could be
possibly derived from the word Synod
which is an assembly of clergyman which
makes a lot more sense in the context of
the boss the main figurehead seems to be
the old man who Grieves us upon starting
the fight he seemed to be a ponzif who
was Walking The Halls of an ancient holy
place that depicted the previous
pontiffs of custodia he talked to these
paintings and told them that one day
they would all escape from their pieces
and become one large colossal being full
of ornaments and blessings allowing them
to sing their hymns for eternity as the
miracle instructed there are multiple
reference to paintings in this dialogue
which makes me believe that they're
referring to Benedictus congregation as
all the paintings located there are
missing their faces whether or not that
is true is unclear and neither option
really gives us anything to go off of
anyway seeing as the paintings are
mentioned outside of this item
description but it might connect to why
sonodo and benedicta are both Sentinels
for the miracle
the final key was given to savonza
Formosa fembra which roughly translates
to beautiful female this boss is the
only one who is connected to another MPC
yerma the key we get from the lady talks
about how the palace could be seen in
the reflection of the lake it was shown
to be ornate and beautiful and thanks to
the miracle Its Reflection would stay
that way even when it took a different
shape even when the palace was crumbled
and rotten the reflection was displayed
as it used to be almost like it had
taken a picture due to its long Decay
The Bell from atop the highest tower
actually sank to the bottom of the lake
never to be seen again until one day
when the villagers noticed that the Bell
had returned but by then it was already
too late as when the bell told the
people's Reflections were warped and
changed in these hideous looking beings
it was known as the curse of the Bell as
these distorted images became reality in
the Hideous forms they saw took shape on
their own faces as for Derma we first
meet her near some dead soldiers who
tells us that she's blinded by hatred
she doesn't tell us much after that but
will elaborate during our next talk by
seeing that her life has been a constant
struggle due to her needing to fulfill a
promise she was given she then goes on
to say that she was one of the people
who were there when the bell told and
turn people's faces into distorted and
hideous Creations yerma also states that
while it was the Bell that caused it it
was the lady's curse that prompted a
bell to ring in the first place the lady
was obsessed with her own reflection as
she was already very beautiful but she
thought of herself as unnaturally Divine
so she prayed that no one would be
allowed to see their reflection within
the lake but that's when the bell rang
and the curse started to spread our last
talk with her is right outside the boss
room where she asks you to join up and
take her down you can choose to do this
if you want to but you'll need some holy
oil first down to the room you need to
go into the Lake's version of the boss
room which opens the door and shows us
the lady sitting and screaming if I had
to give any advice gameplay-wise within
this video please for the love of the
miracle do not enter this room without
giving Yuma the oil I figured that
because it wasn't the boss room I'd be
fine but this opens the door and prompts
rumor to go inside and if she doesn't
have the oil she'll die fortunately
nothing happens after the fight as she
just thanks you for helping her fulfill
her promise but I did have to do a whole
new playthrough for this which was
annoying speaking of annoying something
about this lady's been nagging me all
week and I'm not sure what to make of it
two other NPCs in this game reference
another lady Montanez calls her the Most
Blessed lady and regular calls her a
saint the issue is that the names either
MPC uses never overlap Montanez calls
the Blessed lady extremely beautiful and
the same regular is referring to has an
altar and a statue In Her Image she also
refers to her as beautiful in an item
description but none of their stories
connect to the lady in the lake montane
says a sculpture who witnessed two men
fighting before a woman came by to stop
them only to be killed as a result a
bright radiant light emanated from that
scene which blinded him who despite not
being able to see is still able to
remember the look of the Blessed lady
who I assume is the woman was stabbed
his last and final task is capturing Her
Image in a statue which we can help him
with regular was just a woman who wanted
to try and Avail covered in makeup that
was going to be used for the sculpture
of the saint it specifically refers to
the sculpture as a sculpturist so it's
clearly not Montanez but regardless
after she took off the veil she realized
it had taken her face off she did
however accept the punishment for her
sin and is now trying to keep the
entrance to the sanctuary open so the
saying she is referring to may never be
forgotten the reason I'm so personally
dumbfounded by this is I cannot tell if
these are the same people realistically
it makes sense that the lady would be
ashamed as she was given a key that
unlocks The Birdcage for the witness
Angie was considered extremely beautiful
but there isn't enough concrete evidence
to say that this is a complete fact
similar to my theory with lesmus I don't
consider it a fact just my
interpretation of things I just wanted
to lay out all the information anyway so
you can come to your own conclusions
as a whole though the bosses in the
respective con fraternities are great
there is also a nice amount of
environmental storytelling within the
locations that really bring the whole
thing together such as the numerous
bodies that are strung up across
orospina's domain or the gold oil and
eroded walls in senodo and odon's
buildings but I think my biggest
complaint about the game has to come
from these bosses which I guess also
shows how great the game is if my
biggest problem is a nitpick like this
but a lot of the lores surrounding these
bosses have some of the most extenuating
set of circumstances I have ever seen
with no real explanation as to why
liviana just decided to take lesmus's
head one day and for what and benedicta
decided that today of all days would be
the time to use the Forbidden scroll on
this random Cardinal Blasphemous one had
a lot of weird things too but most of it
was explained away using the miracle or
some other explanation exposito which is
a child that was being cared for by a
moving wicker basket is strange but its
backstory connects back to the game even
though most of it was thanks to the
Miracles doing it at least made sense
when in the context of the high Wills
goals most of these bosses are also
penitents yet I can't recall all any of
their penances being explained I guess
you could claim that guarding the
regrets or the keys is their Penance
which is a fair assumption but it feels
a lot less exciting than the penitent
one's vow of silence or chrysanthe
foregoing her sight I did like what they
did with lesmus and how the miracle
seems to be controlling him against his
will but there's nothing like that with
the other members oraspina talks about
killing benedicta wants you to join her
in her endless orison and Odon doesn't
even speak either way that's really my
biggest issue with the story as I wish
we could learn more about these beings
and while I'm offer speculation and
Theory you can only work with what you
have and it's not much
returning to the story once a lady is
defeated we get the fifth and final key
and our final conversation with the
witness he claims to be given the
opportunity by the miracle to narrate
the events that transpired regarding the
Miracles return he says that the miracle
wanted to create a new icon as it had
been Eon since it left the land of
custodia and needed a way to gain back
support it was meant to be a symbol that
would allow people to unite their face
so they could expand its power as it was
almost extinct due to the lacking
sufficient power though it was only ever
able to manifest itself in disease
deformity and pain this is likely why a
lot of NPCs and some of the bosses seem
to have been given terrible Fates one
person though had asked for hope during
all this pain and suffering and through
the miracle was able to create the heart
in the sky what this is referring to is
the holy verses I mentioned earlier out
of all the statues you could acquire
throughout the game four of them are
specifically carrying golden cloths and
these statues also have item
descriptions that are connected to each
other these holy verses talk about a
malnourished child who made his way to
what he called the Great City but when
he arrived he was filled with sadness as
this great City he had heard about was
surrounded by misery and pain within all
this suffering was the beautiful sky
that was filled with streaks of orange
and pink colors the child was so
unraptured by its beauty he daydreamed
that the clouds molded themselves into a
giant heart from his wish the miracle
was able to take that and create a heart
out of the sky containing its new child
and thus the miracle was given one last
chance of worship
a lot of this is one of those Just go
with it and don't really think too hard
about it kind of stories especially when
you consider that the child's identity
is unknown my first guess would be the
witness but seeing as Blasphemous has
always been allergic to concrete info
I'm not too sure if that's true
regardless what's really important here
is that last part of the verse which
talks about the child inside the heart
being an incarnation of the miracle
itself a symbol in which all faith and
worship from back then till now could be
United basically it's trying to create
God like the literal God the one from
the Bible it's been known since the
first game that the miracle has only
ever been seen through its acts things
like the Twisted one or the plague of
all bro were all acts of the miracle now
in actuality we know it was the high
Wills but still we never saw the miracle
just what it did but now the miracle
wants to make a spokesperson or a
figurehead if you will to relate this to
the real world thanks to the appearance
of God Christians have someone to
worship without him they would just be
worshiping his ax but this is a central
figurehead within the religion this
child is going to be that figurehead
someone to put a face to the name of the
miracle but since we have all the keys
we can stop the miracle from doing so
except stopping us is avaterno who is
also next to chrysanta while the
penitent one was dead chrysanta took the
fight to the penitence we've been
killing throughout the game she seemed
to understand that the heart in the sky
was the Miracle's child so she tried to
stop the miracle from giving birth
unfortunately avaterno was too strong
for chrysanta and she was mortally
wounded during their battle as we know
the miracle had selected specific
Guardians to protect it while it was
busy trying to birth the child with
avaterno being the head of the group his
Penance is actually something we know
which is one of Eternal contemplation he
was basically told to wait until the
miracle said so kind of a boring life if
you ask me but he doesn't seem to mind
as for chrysanta well it gets pretty
obvious what happened she tried to stop
the penitence in the miracle but died at
the hands of evitterno I do have some
additional comments about her due to one
of the post-critic cutscenes but I'm
honestly kind of shocked how dirty the
team did her in this game she may not
have started this way but by the end of
Blasphemous 1 she became quite the
pivotal character and seeing her only
show up for 10 seconds in the intro and
then die kinda sucks with that said
though we can now take the fight to
evitterno who has two phases quite a few
complex moves and even some of the
previous penitence for a brief moment
it's a really solid fight and he without
question lives up to his strength once
that's done though we could take her son
to sword and finish off Eva Turner while
the miracle child is birthed from here
there is only one thing left to do
Ascend and take down the child
foreign
and inscrutable fathers
I am the heir
of your all-encompassing light
this is the Incarnate devotion the final
boss the child of the miracle and God
itself remember when I said earlier how
the miracle wanted for a lack of a
better word a figurehead this is what I
was talking about it literally calls
itself the Miracles magnum opus just
like when Christians think of God when
they pray the people of custodia will
think of this thing when they pray to
the miracle is that terrifying to think
about absolutely but seeing as this
place has a wealth of horrific Creations
this is actually quite tame in
comparison this fight is also another
great example of Blasphemous 2 mimicking
the structure of the previous game is
not only are we killing a God again but
they also made the final boss easier
than the penultimate boss
asker bar not a problem chrysanta drove
me up the goddamn wall I beat the
Incarnate devotion in 30 minutes and I'm
not even using that to brag only as a
comparison as avaterno took me two hours
I don't know what it is with this game
and that specific situation but it's
happened twice now that being said the
fight is fantastic just like in the
first game I had no issues with any of
the bosses when it came to gameplay and
especially their design the final boss
is exactly the kind of thing I would
think of if I were imagining a God but
in the world of Blasphemous it's kind of
like a biblically accurate Angel
extremely holy but also incomprehensible
and very terrifying you'll also notice
that we're attacking its heart which
could be an odd to the Sacred Heart of
Jesus once the boss has been defeated
though we're given our ending if you've
been blitzing through the game and
didn't complete a specific task you'll
be given ending B which is the bad
ending one thing that confuses the child
is what its purpose is which makes sense
given it was just born but through this
trial by combat I learned what was
expected of him the miracle wants the
child to combine itself with the
penitent one to create a new being a new
God and a new age for the mirror called
the second Psalm now there is a book
called The Psalm which is a part of the
Bible and I looked into the second book
of Psalms just to see if there was
anything to it and there could be a
connection here from what I read it
seems like this specific passage is all
about the rulers of the world trying to
thwart God's rule over them God is
attempting to preserve this order of the
world through his anointed one which is
Jesus this perfectly mimics the Miracles
actions of trying to create order within
the chaotic world of Blasphemous through
the child
now as I've stated I've only have a
modicum of knowledge on this thing so
feel free to correct me if I'm wrong but
I do think the phrase second Psalm was
intentional in some way clearly though
that's not a good ending as the
Pennington one is combined with the
child of the miracle to create a new age
one whose future is uncertain but
presumably not good to get the good
ending though we have to go back a bit
you'll notice that while the door behind
the mother is open the fathers isn't
that's because they only open when you
follow the directions on the signs the
mother says to follow the heartbeats
that heralded the birth which is what we
did but the fathers talks about four
envoys wrapped in linen cloths these are
referring to the four golden statues
that have the four holy verses these can
be acquired by completing tasks like
regul statue which is found at the end
of proximo's questline Once all four are
found the door will open and you need to
equip them in order to use the furnace
located inside as the penitent won't put
the statues in the furnace to create the
incense of the envoys its description
reads that these ashes will Mark the
owner worthy of the ultimate sacrifice
allowing them to ascend to the heavens
and that the presence of the envoys
means Absolution and the final step in
the way of penitence this connects to
what happens after the fight as instead
of combining together the Incarnate
devotion dies and the Pennington one is
taken by the cherbs to what the game
calls the canvas of light in time which
I can only assume is heaven inside
though are all of our comrades and
friends from the past rendento perpetva
ezris the guardian visages josinero
sakuro Soledad Lady of the six Sorrows
Deo gracias the Twisted one hell I think
tirso and Vera Diana are in there too
along with our new allies the mother
father and the child from the three
regrets regula and antiata and probably
a couple others I'm forgetting point is
a lot of them are here and were waiting
for us it's just a beautiful ending but
I really think the final line drives it
home
penitence is thus
complete we can now officially say that
after everything we did after killing
two Gods being revived and all the
constant backtracking we did it we're
done and our Penance is complete I
couldn't think of a better ending all
that's missing is chrysantha fortunately
her time may not be over yet as an after
credit cutscene shows a crimson ribbon
similar to the one on her sword implying
that something related to her is soon to
come what this is is unknown but I do
have some theories I'm assuming this is
ending at some kind of DLC whether that
is us trying to revive chrysanta during
the events of the game or maybe a DLC
where we play as her it could also be
like wounds of Evan Titan which a new
ending is released that involves her
it's wishful thinking but I think
somehow Reviving her and having her join
us again and taking down another God
only for both of them to ascend to be
one of the greatest endings I've ever
seen either way that's all the content
we have for now which while filled with
answers does have a lot of questions
still left unanswered my biggest
question involves around and on theater
herself I have a firm belief that she
was the one who revived the pen to one
as she's the first person we meet in a
scene in the ending so I'm assuming she
revived us to prevent the miracle from
succeeding she claims to be from the
holiest of places like the same place we
just saw a moment ago so maybe she had
certain plans set in motion that the
miracle was disrupting or maybe she
simply wanted it gone because it was
causing Havoc she makes reference to
something called The Eternal Pages which
seems to be some kind of book that has
all the rules and events laid out like
it's fate so maybe she's just following
what the pages say but we're really
delving into some vague territory with
that one I another question I personally
have are these dream Realms we visit a
few times the swooping old woman that
has us run through a few gauntlets and
the one who wants us to find lullaby
verses both have this odd dream realm
that we go to get it's ever brought up
regardless let me know what you thought
about Blasphemous too as well as the
video in the comments down below
Blasphemous one really shocked me back
when I played it a year ago and I'm
really glad to be paying another entry
so soon as for what's next for the
series we'll have to wait and see either
way thank you for watching the video
today and I hope you enjoyed make sure
to like And subscribe if you're new and
enjoy this style of story analysis
content and as always think it about
returning viewers for coming back to
another video take care everyone
goodbye